Eric let me start at with you the run of
the photos of the runs on the bank I've
seen it I get it there's people outside
the bank what is the backstory on the
streets of Athens this morning well the
backstory Thomas is pretty much simply
this Athenians and Greeks for that
matter woke up this morning to the
inevitable it was almost inevitable
after tsipras called a referendum on
friday that capital controls would have
to be implemented today to prevent the
economy from spiraling out of control
and allow the government some measure of
control at least or or or yeah let's
call it control over the financial
system which otherwise would have
sustained a much greater run on the bank
than what we see happening now but it's
not really a run on the bank it's a run
on the bank it as much as the capital
controls allow it to happen Greeks are
allowed to withdraw 60 euros a day and
all payments and transfers out of the
country are banned out at least outside
specific situations for which requests
have to be made to the government what
is the response of the other political
parties I think of PASOK and of course
Papandreou as well how are they
responded to the sybaris referendum
there hasn't been much of a ground swell
of response I have to say it's one
o'clock in the afternoon here in Athens
already that as you know things tend to
tart tend rather to start a bit late
here in Greece it wasn't until three
o'clock in the morning that the
government announced that the capital
controls were in fact being put in place
starting with a bank holiday at today
that lasts at least until next Monday
the big question Tom hanging over
everybody's mind first of all let's say
there are two questions do the banks
even reopen next week that is very much
an open question and secondly you
address this with Bonnie and Carl just
moments ago what is the probability of a
Greek exit from the eurozone Mohamed
el-erian whom you're going to be
speaking with puts it at eighty-five
percent he's at the top then you've got
Michael Michael etos for example from
RBS he puts it at forty percent you've
got Hans Redeker from Morgan Stanley at
60 you've got Luigi speranza from BNP
paribas all right it's really a range of
probabilities across the map they kind
of average
250 as a matter of fact but that's not
the here no their haircuts go thank you
so much announces we now move to Berlin
where Hans Nichols has perspective from
a week I in Brussels Hans it has been a
tumultuous weekend dis American will
have the German people behind her this
morning we'll find out in just a little
bit in some ways Merkel doesn't need to
bring the German people along anymore
because negotiations are off right she
would have had a hard time selling a
third deal to the bundestag especially a
third deal that included debt relief it
doesn't look like Bernie where near that
now if you somehow think there's going
to be a new government in Athens
eventually and then in August we come
back for a third negotiations then
Merkel's task is going to be that much
more difficult because there is a fair
amount of public rancor here and frankly
frustration with the Greeks I mean we
just heard from someone briefing of the
finance ministry he said we would have
had no problem with the referendum in
April they don't understand why they're
doing this now at the end of June well
hon speaking of the referendum yesterday
late afternoon Jean told you were the
President of the European Union
Commission tweeted out a link to the
press release directed towards the
people of Greece he tweeted in Greek and
in English is this to counter in some
way it suppresses push for a no vote
because he's basically putting out a
referendum and saying vote no for this
oh absolutely i mean european officials
are trying to work the refs I mean the
Greek public is not a u.s. jury under
sequestration you can try to influence
them and it's gonna go both ways you'll
hear a variety of sweeteners potentially
from Europe all week one quick note
though on that on that tweet that was
put out a close ally of mr. tsipras took
a picture of that very that very
document held it up and tweeted that out
and said this so-called non-existent
ultimatum so clearly there's a war of
words going on between Greek officials
in the syriza party and a lot of
European officials that want to see
Greece somehow come back into the fold
but we're going to have a lot of
attempts here especially in Germany and
elsewhere in Europe to try to convince
the Greek public before they vote that
they should vote yes guys Hans a
question here from Karl what
is your sense of the unity among the the
hardliners here in the euro zone between
the Germans and maybe the softer line
taken by the the French and the Dutch
and some of the other rough yeah
ministers the ditcher the Germans have
been vindicated in their skepticism that
serezha was ever really serious about a
deal and so you heard mr. set pan this
morning say he was surprised but
pessimistic in some ways the French are
sounding more like the Germans guys Hans
Nichols thank you so much in Berlin this
morning quickly to John Farrow and
London John you mentioned the Swiss
intervention we're gonna see a lot more
like this would you presume we will see
central bank or ganized action this
morning it depends on a number of things
tom I mean for what it tells you how
global it is but number two it's the
issue of duration the Swiss National
Bank face and continued upward pressure
on the Swiss prank Thomas yard and the
president of the SMB telling me only two
weeks ago that it faced significant
pressure significantly overvalued so
their reaction was a pretty obvious one
they intervened for me and everyone else
the question is duration and how long it
goes on for you can have spreads widen
but if that goes on for two three four
days then we start to think about the
ECB's role in all of this the QE issue
what is it going to take for them to
increase QE one day sell-off won't do
that two three four five days of
aggressive right link of spreads that
may just do it and the other question
for you guys sitting over there in New
York is what is Janet Yellen do everyone
anticipated in that first rate hike
since 2006 to come in September if this
continues through the summer maybe the
feds got something extra to think about
as well John Farrell thank you so much
greatly appreciated we think Erik
schatzker Hans Nichols and John Farrell